The only real sports are
auto racing, bullfighting,
and mountain climbing.
The rest are just games.
Never heard that one.
You never heard that?
Classic Hemingway.
You've got to use that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We have a combined 60 years
of rock climbing experience
at an elite level.
The Dawn Wall was my quest to
really find my physical limits.
It's still considered the
hardest big-wall free-climb
in the world.
Free solo climbing
means climbing
with no rope to protect you.
The fact that he was the
first one to free solo El Cap
was such a big deal.
People didn't think that it
would ever get free soloed.
The lessons that
you take from climbing
around success and failure
helps put the rest of life
in perspective.
Climbing is like a fine
spice that brings out
the flavor of the rest of life.
We have spent quite a bit of
time refining our own climbing.
And we are happy to share
that knowledge with anybody
who's interested in the sport.
Footwork is generally the
most important part of climbing.
It all looks horrendously
uncomfortable.
But you get used to it.
The point of using your
arms in rock climbing
is to keep you
balanced over your feet
so that your feet can
push you up the wall.
98% of bouldering
is just falling off.
Falling over and over.
You're just like
[GROANS] This is actually
a perfect example of where
technique matters because right
now I'm hanging
off two holds, kind
of strenuous on the fingers.
But instead, I can lean in and
push my knee against the wall.
Look, I can suddenly
go no hands.
We also sprinkle in a little
bit of the psychological aspects
of the sport.
And how to not
look like a Gumby.
It's a fun term for a beginner.
If you're wearing your climbing
shoes in the parking lot,
you're Gumby-ing.
Climbing is a really incredible
way to connect with nature.
[SCREAMING] All of my
craziest experiences,
all my hardest experiences,
all my best experiences
are all associated
with climbing.
I've made pretty
intentional choices
with the way I lead my life.
I welcome anybody
else to do the same.
That doesn't mean to free solo.
I mean to think about
their life critically.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm Tommy Caldwell.
And I'm Alex Honnold.
And this--
BOTH: --is my MasterClass.
We've totally [BLEEP].
I'm Tommy Caldwell.
And I'm Alex Honnold.
BOTH: And this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MasterClass, don't be a Gumby.